Since I split custody,
and there's times where my kids are gone
for days at a time,
I like to just head over to my boyfriend's house
and get some of my work done
and just do some stuff over there.
And this bag I got from the TikTok shop
has made my life going back and forth so much easier.
I used to pack, like,
three or four backpacks
and literally look like I was moving in.
But now I can really,
absolutely pack multiple outfits for multiple days.
I can fit, um,
gym clothes,
extra shoes,
my big ass sweater
so that I stay warm.
I still have room to put all my little
extra trinkets and things in my hair product.
This bag has been a true lifesaver.
I absolutely love it.
It's on sale right now on the TikTok shop,
and it's linked right here if you wanna get one.